VICTIMS.
APPARENTLY, HE IS BEING CHARGED
WITH LYING TO CONGRESS.
THAT IS CRAZY CONSIDERING
CONGRESS CANNOT BE CHARGED WITH
LYING TO YOU WHICH IT DOES
CONSTANTLY.
BUT ROGER STONE'S REAL CRIME WAS
GIVING DONALD TRUMP POLITICAL
ADVICE FOR 30 YEARS.
FOR THAT, HE FACES LIFE BEHIND
BARS.
ONE PERSON WHO CLEARLY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING AND STRONGLY APPROVES
OF IT IS A PRESIDING JUDGE IN
THE CASE, AMY BERMAN JACKSON.
SHE IS AN OBAMA APPOINTEE AND
TRANSPARENTLY AND AGGRESSIVELY
POLITICAL.
MONTHS AGO, JACKSON PROHIBITED
ROGER STONE FROM PUBLICLY
DEFENDING HIMSELF IN THE CASE.
CNN AND MSNBC WERE FREE TO
CONTINUE TO SLANDER STONE AND OF
COURSE, THEY RELENTLESSLY DID
THAT.
BUT IF THE STONE SET A SINGLE
WORD IN HIS OWN DEFENSE, JACKSON
VOWED TO PUT HIM BEHIND BARS.
HOW CAN JACKSON DO THAT IN A
COUNTRY WITH A FIRST AMENDMENT?
SHE COULDN'T.
IT IS BLATANTLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
BUT DONALD TRUMP IS HATED HERE
IN WASHINGTON SO NOBODY STOPPED
HER.
JACKSON JUST DID IT ANYWAY, JUST
LIKE IN THE THIRD WORLD.
JACKSON'S BEHAVIOR IN COURT HAS
TURNED OUT TO BE EVEN MORE
LUDICROUS AND UNPROFESSIONAL,
ASSUMING THAT IS POSSIBLE.
AT TIMES, SHE HAS LITERALLY
ROLLED HER EYES AND SNORTED AT
STONE, SUGGESTING HE IS GUILTY
BEFORE THE TRIAL EVEN STARTED.
HER JUDGMENTS HAVE BEEN
TRANSPARENTLY POLITICAL BEARD
YESTERDAY FOR EXAMPLE DURING
JURY SELECTION, ONE OF THE
PROSPECTIVE JURORS TURNED OUT TO
BE A FORMER PRESS SECRETARY OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHO
ADMITTED THAT SHE DESPISES
DONALD TRUMP AND HAS FRIENDS IN
THE FEDERAL PROSECUTORS OFFENSE,
WHICH IS TRYING THE CASE.
HER HUSBAND, MEANWHILE, WORKS AT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHICH IS
PROSECUTING ROGER STONE.
THE WOMAN CLAIMED SHE FOLLOWED
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
CLOSELY BUT SOMEHOW HAD NEVER
READ ANYTHING ABOUT
ROGER STONE'S CASE AND DIDN'T
HAVE A STRONG OPINION ABOUT IT.
NO SOBER PERSON COULD TAKE THAT
CLAIM SERIOUSLY.
BUT AMY BERMAN JACKSON DID.
SHE ACTED LIKE IT WAS ALL
COMPLETELY FINE.
ROGER STONE'S LAWYERS ASKED THAT
THAT WOMAN BE REMOVED FROM THE
JURY POLE, JACKSON REFUSED.
PERSONAL CONFLICTS WERE NOT
"AUTOMATICALLY DISQUALIFYING."
WHAT OUGHT TO BE AUTOMATICALLY
DISQUALIFYING IS AMY BERMAN
JACKSON'S BEHAVIOR FROM THE
BENCH.
NO FAIR PERSON COULD CONDONE IT.
IF THEY WERE STILL ON HIS
LIBERALS LEFT IN THIS COUNTRY
THEY WOULD BE PROTESTING OUTSIDE
THE COURTROOM.
WELL, AND ANGER OVER AT ABC NEWS
DID SOMETHING PRETTY UNUSUAL FOR
THAT NETWORK.
SHE INADVERTENTLY TOLD THE TRUTH
ABOUT WHAT HER NETWORK IS DOING
TO PROTECT A BILLIONAIRE